You've just worked through a batch of tricky problems with Sarah. And maybe the
results of the programs were not always what you expected. That's why it's such
a good idea to test your programs to see that they produce the right result.
Testing is incredibly important in software engineering. And when testing isn't
done right, the results can be quite dramatic. Over here, you see the lift off
of a rocket, an Ariane rockets off the European space agency that unfortunately
a few seconds afterward explodes in midair. Now what happened here is that the
rocket had a device to maintain its position and it actually had two backups.
And because of that, the rocket engineers didn't think they had to test it. But
both back ups failed for the exact same reason actually and testing really
would have been beneficial in this case. So let's learn more about how you can
test your own programs. Okay, here we are in BlueJ, and I'm going to write a
program that tests the translate method of rectangles. Let's have a look. Here,
we construct a rectangle, we call the translate method. We print out what
happens to the x coordinate and we also print out what happens to the width of
the rectangle. And now for the important part. The important part is that
before compiling the program, we also think what should it do? And it is
really, really important that you think about that right when you write your
test program. Here is a super easy way of doing that. You simply add a print
statement that prints what you expect that this program should do. Hmm, what do
we expect? Let's see. The x coordinate of the rectangle is at 5, the y
coordinate is at 10. And now, we translate it by 25 pixels to the right and 15
pixels down. So we have a 5. Translated by 25 pixels, so we expect that the x
coordinate is now 30 pixels, and that's what I'm putting here. What about the
width? The width is 60 and moving the rectangle shouldn't change it, so we'll
expect this to be 60 again. So this is a good example of a Tester program. We
do something. We print the results and we print the expected results. let's
quickly run the program. We have the actual x position of 30 and the expected
position of 30. And similarly we have the actual width of 60 at the expected
width of 60 so the actual and the expected Matchup. That's great. So, the
simple lesson is always print the actual and the expected results. Sarah has an
activity where you can write you're own test program and practice this.